you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
this video is part of an ongoing series
in collaboration with upload VR the
series will cover the emerging
technology of the VR and AI industry and
what it means for the world we live in
virtual reality and augmented reality
they seem to be hot buzzwords which have
all heard before but what are they
exactly and what's the difference
between them in this video we'll take a
look let's start with VR in simple terms
VR is a computer-generated simulation or
replacement of one's environment for
example you put on a headset it blocks
out your worldview and substitute the
digital world that's designed to fool
your senses from the point of view of
your brain you're somewhere else it's a
form of mental teleportation if you will
so where did VR come from there's going
to be a full video on the history of VR
but the basic gist is as follows the
origins of VR as a technology system can
be traced back to 1962 when filmmaker
Mort Heilig created the sensorama it was
an arcade style cabinet with a 3d
display vibrating seat stereo sound fan
and sense producer one of the
experiences was riding a motorcycle down
the streets of Brooklyn a viewer would
have a 3d view of the streets while
having the wind blow in their face while
simultaneously feeling the vibration of
the motorcycle seat and even
experiencing the smells of the city
although it was absolutely revolutionary
for the time the idea largely didn't
gain traction
most people point to MIT computer
scientist ivan sutherland as being the
godfather of VR displays in 1968 he
created the sword of damocles the first
VI headset he and his colleagues at MIT
started the first virtual headset
experiments as a side point Sutherland
was a low-key genius he also invented
sketch pad in 1963 an advanced software
for computer-aided design and a
breakthrough in human-computer
interaction but more on this in the full
history video it wouldn't be until 1987
when the actual term virtual reality was
coined the term was the brainchild of
Jaron Lanier an American computer
philosopher and computer scientist let's
break down the actual meaning of virtual
reality virtual means being something in
effect though not an actuality or in
fact this is from mid 15th century
English so in other words
ideally VI is an approximation of our
reality that is digital but not reality
itself since its inception in the late
60s VR Hardware has existed largely in
university research labs in hilariously
big and bulky forms never to test the
waters of mainstream consumer product
but more for an understanding of the
limits of our brains perception systems
it was also a helpful tool for PTSD and
cognitive behavior therapy patients over
the years various companies such as
Nintendo and NEC have tried bringing VR
to the consumer market but these efforts
were major failures the reasons for the
industry's previous failures will be
looked at in future videos but broadly
speaking the technology just wasn't
there and the threshold for building and
convincing headset was too high until
now currently VR is quickly becoming
extremely relevant to gamers 3d artists
architects and real estate agents
teachers and students and even
astronauts after crying wolf a number of
times VR is finally showing some promise
this time around
okay let's move on to augmented reality
augmented reality also known as mixed
reality is a different beast from VR
this is because its main purpose isn't
to cut out the real world and transport
you to another one but rather is to be
an enhancement of your real world with a
set of magical virtual objects in it
when a person's real environment is
supplemented or augmented with
computer-generated images usually motion
tracked then that's augmented reality so
if you play Pokemon go when that was a
thing or have you snapchat lens face
filters then you've already used
primitive forms of augmented reality
here's another day-to-day but fairly
amusing example of augmented reality
from a third person point of view the
roads have been cleared we're ready to
get back out on the roads let's bring
this car out actually into augmented
reality and show you what I'm talking
about
because you hit the roads the roads are
clear visibility looks great right you
think there's no problem but then you
get behind this guy you know the one
that doesn't clear the snow and the ice
officer the term augmented reality is
attributed to a former Boeing researcher
Thomas Corder in 1990 augment is from
the Latin word or guerra which means to
increase or to add hence a our
technology is adding to our existing
reality Carolee augmented reality is
also showing promise with efforts like
microsoft's hololens and a very
secretive magically project so let's
take a quick summary of those
technologies virtual reality tends to be
completely immersive with no real-world
stimuli affecting the experience the
goal of VR is to make the user feel as
if they are in fact in another place in
stark contrast to this augmented reality
acts as a digital addition to the user's
world for example objects can appear on
tables information can be displayed in
floating windows and graphics can be
generated all seamlessly motion tracked
to the users field
you the thing that makes AI and we are
different from any other forms of
technology is that it directly affects
the perceptions and processes of the
human mind in an obvious way if the only
technology that can provide actual
packaged experiences while there are a
large number of people that do think
both AI and V are a fad that will fade
out like previous hype cycles of the
technology from the 80s and 90s the
thing to note here is that the
underlying technology is vastly more
powerful this time around and it's very
much feasible think of it as a time
that's parallel to smartphones just
before the iPhone we just need the right
blend of killer AR and VR applications
product price and consumer demand to
really begin the altered reality spark
at current rates by 2025 attractive AR
and VR experiences will be commonplace
if done right
these technologies show incredible
potential thanks for watching guys this
was just an introductory video and
there'll be more videos coming in a
series with our played VR rest assured
plenty of interesting topics will be
covered so this has been to gogo you've
been watching cold fusion don't forget
to subscribe if you just stumbled across
this channel and I'll catch you again
soon for the next video cheers guys have
a good one
[Music]
coldfusion accusing
[Music]
you
[Music]